okay Hillary's debate attacks on Trump
were effective in yesterday's third and
final presidential debate Donald Trump's
fear-mongering was also I believe
effective at least when it comes to
impacting his base I want to play a clip
for you here where Donald Trump talks
about mothers of children who have been
killed by undocumented immigrants this
is really red meat fear-mongering zena
phobic stuff from Trump and although the
more rational voter understands that
this is completely bogus nonsense my
sense is and who Who am I really to
figure out how a trumpeter thanks but I
I think we've developed sort of a
picture of the average trumpeter Trump
'used during this campaign I think the
trumpets like this type of stuff let's
take a look mr. Trump you go first in
that segment you have two minutes well
first of all she wants to give amnesty
which is a disaster and very unfair to
all of the people the waiting on line
for many many years we need strong
borders in the audience tonight we have
four mothers of I mean these are
unbelievable people that I've gotten to
know over a period of years whose
children have been killed brutally
killed by people that came into the
country illegally you have thousands of
mothers and fathers and relatives all
over the country they're coming in
illegally drugs are pouring in through
the border we have no country if we have
no border so Trump they're relying on
that no country we're going to have a
country thing this is the type of
fear-mongering that a less skilled
debater than Hillary Clinton would
probably have been damaged by that line
that sequence played quite well from
Donald Trump with the xenophobic
nativist crowd but then Hillary Clinton
was able to talk about how we do need to
bring undocumented immigrants out of the
shadows when they become part of the
formal economy it's better for everybody
but here is Hillary Clinton's counter
attack on Trump and she slammed him in a
way that I thought was very effective
let's take a look what I am also arguing
is that bringing undocumented immigrants
out from
shadows putting them into the formal
economy will be good because that
employers can't exploit them and
undercut Americans wages and Donald
knows a lot about this he used
undocumented labor to build the Trump
Tower he underpaid undocumented workers
and when they complained he basically
said what a lot of employers do you
complain I'll get you deported I want to
get everybody out of the shadows get the
economy working and not let employers
like Donald exploit undocumented workers
which hurts them but also hurts American
workers this is such a key issue in this
race which is that Donald Trump claims
to be the solution to many of the
problems that he is personally a part of
and we've talked about this when it
comes to sending jobs to China and
Mexico and now Hillary Clinton multiple
times actually during this debate what
two or three times this was just one of
them pointing out that Donald Trump for
all his talk about trade deals and trade
law and whatever he brought in Chinese
steel to contract construct at least one
building and i believe it's more
although i don't have the exact list in
front of me uh Trump did not respond to
that specific allegation because he
cannot respond to that specific
allegation because it is true and there
is no defense of it and the
fear-mongering that Trump came out with
with some nice red meat for the right
but Hillary Clinton doing a good job of
turning that back around I've talked
about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zipcar which gets you
a car when you want it when you need it
they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David